we have been covering the chaos at
Facebook that has sort of stemmed from
the misuse and release of data for 50
million users in connection with
Cambridge analytic ah which was Donald
Trump's opposition research data mining
and digital strategy company during the
2016 election we've covered all of that
stuff I guess in the last week most of
it is has broken founder and CEO of
Facebook Mark Zuckerberg was interviewed
by CNN's Laurie Segall a few days ago he
said he's sorry about what happened that
it was really a major major mistake big
ball drop by Facebook and part of the
blowback to this has been that the
British Parliament has asked that Mark
Zuckerberg go there and talk about what
the hell happened and Zuckerberg is now
effectively refusing instead even though
he was the one requested whose presence
was requested Facebook is sending one or
a few senior executives at the company
even though again UK Parliament said we
want Mark Zuckerberg to show up here
he's the founder he's the CEO he's the
one who ultimately has to answer for
this and the explanation for Facebook is
as follows Facebook fully recognizes the
level of public and parliamentary
interest in these issues and support
your belief that these issues must be
addressed at the most senior levels of
the company by those in an authoritative
position to answer your questions as
such mr. Zuckerberg has personally asked
one of his deputies to make themselves
available to give evidence to the
committee that's a letter from Rebecca
Stimson who runs a public policy for
Facebook in the UK UK Parliament is
saying okay yeah that's really great but
we want to hear from Mark Zuckerberg
will even set up a video link if
necessary maybe he'd be willing to do it
by like Facebook video chat or something
like that so it's unclear what's next
and I don't find this at all shocking
Zuckerberg in his interview with a
Laurie Segall on CNN said something
along the lines of I'm paraphrasing here
I'd be glad to appear if I'm the right
person which was very clearly setting
himself up to later say hey you know
what turns out
I'm not the right person we're gonna
send somebody else and the effect is
that the PR is really building here the
bad press is really building Facebook
has had they have a massive user base so
Facebook's not disappearing anytime soon
but they're starting to see a wave of
people getting off of Facebook
there are how-to guides going viral
about how to totally close your Facebook
account if you want to that are popping
up all over the Internet
there's advertisers pulling away from
Facebook Mozilla has bailed Germany's
second biggest bank is out American auto
parts company Pep Boys is out that's
just the start of the list and Mozilla
is even going further Mozilla launched
an extension to their browser called
Facebook container which will isolate
the Facebook identity of the user from
the rest of their web activity
preventing some of that tracking that
follows you throughout the internet
which then is sort of reflected in
highly targeted Facebook ads to you so
Facebook has lost a hundred billion
dollars in market cap from stock market
declines they're having a problem now
that gets us to the decision to not send
Zuckerberg right from a PR perspective
unless you think Zuckerberg his
appearance will be so bad that it will
do more damage to Facebook than the
improvement in the perception of the
company that it might cause then you
should send him right if you're choosing
not to send Zuckerberg when the request
is for him specifically after all the
bad press that means that either
Zuckerberg himself or Facebook believe
that if they send him we're gonna end up
in an even worse position than where we
are now which is scary because it's
already pretty bad so I'm curious as to
what the logic is the truth is that even
Facebook's deputies haven't done too
well in the past I don't have the video
handy here but there was an incident
where a facebook representative went
before the Singapore Parliament and
answered questions and if they send the
same arrogant clown I don't remember the
guys name I can see why there would be
hesitation to send anybody at all but I
get it I mean Zuckerberg is not
experienced in dealing with negative PR
and adversarial interviews he's the big
vision guy he shows up for the new prod
announcements and for talking about the
trajectory of facebook over the next two
years it's very possible that if you
send Zuckerberg in he gets crushed under
questioning maybe but he should be able
to defend his own company under pressure
he should be able to testify before the
UK Parliament I think and it's kind of a
shame I guess I mean he was such a
rising star maybe like a 2020 darling
worth about sixty billion dollars and
now it seems like he's only gonna go
down from here yeah I mean I don't know
I don't know anything about the 2020
stuff but I can't imagine this guy's
gonna be the next president of the
United States that I can tell you at
this point and we'll see where this
shakes out I mean the first week after
the the initial hit of bad PR can make
it sort of hard to predict where this is
going but you're seeing user abandonment
you're also seeing advertiser
abandonment I'm confident Facebook is a
massive massive company I'm confident
they will get through this the question
as to what degree will their reputation
be affected today's program is sponsored
in part by brilliant if you watch our
channel or listen to the podcast yeah
you're into politics and you follow the
Daily News and you want to be informed
about the world around you but maybe you
also want to dig a little deeper and on
the program we talk about climate change
taxes and Technology political
philosophy to really understand these
issues at a deeper fundamental level you
have to familiarize yourself with with
what's actually sort of underpinning all
of it and that's math and philosophy and
the hard sciences and Social Sciences
and that's where brilliant comes in it's
a truly unique and innovative online
learning service which lets you master
important real-world math and science
concepts this includes probability and
statistics logic and problem solving
renewable energy climate science
criminology you name it and you can get
started right the second by signing up
for free at brilliant org slash David
Pakman the first 200 people who do that
at brilliant org slash David Pakman will
also qualify for 20% off an annual
premium membership that is brilliant org
slash David Pakman check it out today